hello everyone and welcome to another
game from the uh air things masters this
is the second match andrey sipenko
versus yanni ponyshi and this is uh well
it just went terribly wrong for one of
the players as pretty much as soon as
they left the
safety of the waters of known theory uh
so let's dive straight into it and see
what happens so it's pink with the white
pieces opens with e4 this is game two
game one ended in a draw and we're going
to discuss a little bit about the other
results after the game so e5 by nipple
knight to f3 we have knight to c6 and
the bishop to b5 all right spencer goes
for the rui lopez we have a6 morpheus
defense bishop to a4 and now knight to
f6 we are in the columbus variation we
have castles and bishop to e7 d3
we have b5 challenging the bishop bishop
b3 b6 and c3 soul very very standard
stuff nothing new here happening castles
and now h3 uh we have bishop to b7
getting the bishop on this long diagonal
bishop to c2 and now rook to e8 so again
nothing um a new happening here rook to
e1 and now bishop to f8 standard idea
here uh knight b to d2 and here we have
knight the e7 and this is now a new move
already now as of move 12 which for roy
lopez is very impressive
uh so here is pinko goes after the queen
side as one usually does against this
setup so a4
we have knight to g6 now the knight
might have some ideas of coming to f4
and now knight to f1 now this knight can
come to e3 to g3 and also the bishop now
covers f4 uh so as the nothing is really
defending the d5 square we have the
early d5 by nipple
and now comes knight to g3 here you you
probably have to go for the very sharp
d4 and then everything just gets traded
off with a with a pretty much equal
position but yes pink who goes knight to
g3 as that f5 square is looking very
very appealing to the white knight uh
but now c5 and look at this beautiful
expansion anjapo has in the center
and again probably you have to just go
for trades here captures captures
captures on a8 queen captures and now
play something like maybe h4 h5 uh with
um it not being all that impressive for
white because you simply allowed all of
this for black but again it's much
better than what actually happened in
the game here is panko played bishop to
d2 and now nipple gets a couple of moves
in we have h6 and now he goes for b4 so
a a different plan than going for that
um trade
c4 by nipple and this will now be a
problem for white because it's very hard
to get rid of this uh
pawn and well it just creates a very
strong outpost for black on the d3
square once the position clears up so d
captures on c4 b captures on c4 and now
e captures on d5 we have queen captures
and e5 uh now you have to be careful if
the knight moves you might get
checkmated on g2 so the knight for the
moment can't go anywhere
uh and here uh uh white plays bishop
captures on g6 yes it's a way to double
uh black spawns and it seems like
something you should do uh but maybe
there are some better moves like bishop
to e3 quickly go for that queen trade
and uh for the end game as soon as
possible uh but okay bishop captures on
g6 was played f captures on g6 and only
now bishop to e3
but now queen to f7 and this is a very
nice square for the black queen that was
not available before the trade on g6 as
you will see so queen to f7
now comes knight to d2 and of course
knight to d5 now just putting pressure
on white's position
and uh later on you will play rook 88
and bring the rook to d3 for the moment
not all that much white can do about
this so here we have knight g to e4
defending the c3 pawn like this but now
not a knight captures here but rather
knight to f4 uh where you could go for
bishop captures on f4 but that just
seems like uh giving too much to black
because the bishop is here pawn can come
to f3 uh the the rook and queen doing uh
good work here if the knight moves even
bishop the
d6 might be an option in the future uh
so here probably f3 has to be played and
then okay to d8 and look at black's
setup it's just
um very very enjoyable so instead after
knight to f4 we have f3 andrei just uh
defends the knight on e4 uh and now rook
a to d8 of course we put the rook on the
d file the queen is still in d1 and we
want to get the rook to d3 so here queen
c2 on pinning and now rook to d3 so just
a beautiful beautiful position for black
and white probably uh should play
something like b5 create a pass pawn and
then figure out
where to go from there but in the game i
spin completely missed the the threat uh
black prepared here he played knight to
f2 he wanted to kick away the rook from
d3 but now the position is completely
lost for ac panko so feel free to pause
the video here and win the game for
nipple while i give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting that you
can actually eliminate all of the
defenders of the f3 pawn and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is rook capture sunday too so
congratulations to everyone who found
this it is not easy to see through all
of this mess
and now you have to react to this you
have to capture the rook and it doesn't
really matter what you capture the rook
with so here bishop captures on d2 was
played and now again we remove the
defender of the f3 pawn knight captures
on g2 beautiful stuff here by nipple the
problem is if king captures then it's
just uh well queen captures on f3 with
check king to f1 now we go for the king
hunt queen g2 check king has to go to e2
now bishop f3 check forcing the king up
the board as the bishop now covers d1
king to e3 and now we uh
free up the f3 square for the black
queen we're threatening checkmate here
and not a lot uh white can do to stop
this you can try some like knight g4 but
then bishop e7 bishop to g5 is coming
and that's a game
uh so that would happen if the knight is
actually accepted so here is pengo tried
rook to e4 and it's a valiant attempt uh
as
well bishop captures on e4 would go a
long way but of course nipple not
interested in that he just plays queen
captures on f3 still keeps all the
pressure here along this diagonal and
we'll just ask so what do you play here
with white uh we have rook to g4 now at
least the rook will be guarding the g2
squared and i will be guarding the h1
square so maybe you you won't get
checkmated that quickly and you are
going for queen captures on g6 so maybe
there is some counterplay here so here
h5
asking what do you do with the rook and
it's again not easy once the rook moves
for example if you move it to g5 we're
going to play knight to h4
and again such in such an ugly position
for white not a lot of moves for white
and the simple for example e for e3 is
enough for black to win the game so here
is pinko try's queen captures on g6 now
offering a rook here
but ian just plays knight to f4 uh he
attacks the queen here uh puts again a
lot of pressure on black space on white
position and the thing is if you move
the queen then knight captures an h3
with a nice royal fork
fork here also the knight is included in
the fork i don't know if this fork has a
name a queen a knight and knight fork uh
maybe it does i i'm not sure but after
knight captures on h3 we're just going
to capture on g4 and again there's no
move here for white so instead after
knight to f4 rook captures and f4 was
played uh is pinko would very gladly
give up some material to uh you know
just alleviate the pressure uh but now e
captures on f4 and okay for the moment
the knight and queen covering all the
important squares so you don't get
checkmated but now after bishop captures
on f4 now we have rook to e2 and he was
in this position on move 32 that is
penko resigned to the game as there is
nothing more to be done here
problem is if you uh defend the the
knight here let's say you play something
like queen to g3 uh we just play rook
captures on f2 and that's it there's no
way to play this uh because if you
capture with the queen you get
checkmated queen to h1 is checkmate uh
and if you don't if you capture the
queen we just capture back and now we
are up a full piece there's no
compensation here for white and another
thing let's say after rook to a2 you
don't play queen g3 you play something
else you can play bishop to g3 then the
queen no longer guards the g2 square of
course you just get checkmated so
nothing works here and after rook to e2
is penko resigned the game
uh if you guys are interested what
happened next i will now mention uh so
for those of you who still don't want to
know the results of the other games uh
don't listen to it
any further uh but magnus won his match
against uh uh artemia if he won game one
and game two and then game two three
ended in a draw
artemy was pushing a little bit but
nothing really uh serious happening
there so magnus was the first one to
qualify for the finals and here after
game two uh nipple also won game three
and as game one ended in a draw that
means nipple advances to the finals and
in the finals of the earthings masters
we will have another clash after the
world chess championship match between
magnus carlsen and yanipanishi so we'll
see what happens only this will not be
decided in one day like all the matches
so far but it will be
over two days over friday and uh and
saturday uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it really uh wild stuff
here uh you know uh
so many so many pieces here very easy to
miss this idea uh but you know who would
who would hope hope that uh you could
actually remove all of the defenders of
the f3 pawn but that's exactly what you
have to look for
and that's how you will find attacking
chances like nipple did in this game uh
so once again hope you guys enjoyed it i
would like to thank ryan urban cloud
strife andre theron cypher kicks and leo
joel born for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing uh the coverage of the finals
uh until it ends uh so uh thank you all
i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day